I just want people to prove their love
for me we asked three couples and
they're BFFs to play a game to see who
really knew each other the best does
your BFF know you better than your
significant other how long have you
known your significant other spend about
a year we've been dating for two and a
half years we met working at BuzzFeed my
friend t8 her class and I was like yo
who's the blonde we joined a gay bowling
league how long have you known your BFF
we've known each other two years two
years but it feels like a lifetime we've
known each other for about a year almost
four years I thought we went to camp
together but we had it I thought we were
dating but we weren't we met through
work I was the only one in the whole
entire play that knew he was actually
gay like he wasn't out yet what is their
favorite breed of dog
kakapo because that's what my dog is a
dog I'll hammer go that's what that I
said my dog can you give away with a
miniature schnauzer that you had Shetty
terrier English who do they talk to you
on the phone the most what celebrity
would they hook up with okay
I'm not even King star Joe is up there
a little wire what is their greatest
strength I said making people laugh
funny listening joke her legs
I said I see the good in everything and
everyone and I said you care about
everyone else
yeah that's a big car I think you're
gonna write here the big day
what is their weirdest ritual instead of
just like applying moisturizer like this
yep she fills it in her hands
painful and goes like this yep I like
always do my hair I wear hat boom in bow
hair okay also that's an area I get on
Justin all the time cuz he walks in late
every day I crossed my fingers because
when somebody is talking I don't want to
interrupt what is their biggest pet
peeve being late well you right lying or
not going to bed bye thank you oh I
wrote shoes in the house or on stuff I
said people who are fake I just hate
when we're like oh wow people and then
people cheering with their mouths open
yeah I'm glad that the game was so close
between Gabi and I that way I don't feel
like a terrible boyfriend and Gabi
feel like a bad friend they're just both
kind of average acquaintances of absence
I'm taking back up PFF no I feel so much
love right now I got my crew right here
oh here's your thumbnail oh this is
[ __ ] still don't think this is right
I still know you better what's your
favorite ice cream wrong